are you still playing overwatch well I
am too and I'm always excited for the
next skins and heroes to be revealed you
just never know what Blizzard is going
to come up with and GameSpot recently
learned that the developer was once
considering a cat for one of its heroes
I'm Matt in this game spot news update
is all about those fluffy little kiddies
overwatch director jeff kaplan told
GameSpot that early in development
Blizzard tried to figure out how far
their boundaries were for what type of
characters they could add talking
gorilla Winston was on one end of the
spectrum while dude with a gun soldier
76 was on another one hero that didn't
fit inside of this however was a jetpack
controlled by a cat yep you heard that
right the cat would lie inside of the
jetpack and pot the controls every once
in a while unfortunately Blizzard
thought they had gone too far and I mean
like they're probably right but still
how awesome would that be anyway we'll
keep you updated as / watches next
heroes are revealed so be sure to LIKE
and subscribe to stay on top of that
another overwatch hero that Blizzard
considered was a hockey player and as a
Canadian I'd probably trade lucio and
both of his hockey theme skins for that
the rest of our interview goes in-depth
on making character tweaks pechangaaahhh
eng and the type of shampoo Kaplan uses
you can read the full thing on gamespot
com but if you want to master the
shooters latest hero check out our guide
on the walking tank orissa
[Music]